hi my name's Wayne Piekarski and I work
as a developer advocate at Google today
I'm going to talk about Android wear and
how you can take advantage of adding
pages to your existing notifications if
you're just getting started
you first might want to view some of our
previous dev bytes you'll also want to
get set up with the Android wear
developer preview and get it working on
your machine so let's write an Android
wear application that helps keep track
of library books then I'm borrowing for
my next adventure so the app will
generate notifications whenever books
have borrowed or overdue to be returned
to the library on a phone there'll be a
single notification indicating how many
books are overdue
so with an Android wear device this is
easily glanceable on your wrist and you
can see the notification without pulling
your phone out of your pocket
now since wearable displays are quite
small there's a limit to what you can
see in a single glance however so what
can we do about this with Android wear
we support adding extra pages to a
notification allowing you to swipe
sideways and see a lot more information
on the wearable we can see the specific
titles and authors of each book that are
overdue and there can be some kind of
action at the end as well so how do we
go and implement all this for a phone
application your code will currently be
traversing some kind of array or a list
of books within a look like this and
then calculating how many are overdue
from it you're probably already doing
this to generate the main notification
you can see here on the phone screenshot
at the bottom there to add extra pages
what you do is you modify your code to
keep a list of extra notifications so
here I've created an ArrayList which we
were used to store these for use later
you would now modify your loop to
generate a new notification for each
overdue item with whatever text you want
inside of it like this code here and you
should add each of these into your
ArrayList for use later on so adding the
extra pages to your code is now really
really easy so this is what your
existing code might look like right now
and then we now make a call to a method
called add pages and this takes in a
collection so you can just pass any
extras list you created earlier as a
single argument so he can see it's just
a one line change so make sure you also
use the new notification manager compat
instead of a notification manager from
the framework so the new notifications
are work properly with wearable
vices and finally you can combine pages
with the stack feature that was
discussed in my previous dev byte so
there are lots of combinations that are
possible here based on whatever you want
to do so that's it for pages it's a
really very simple way of adding extra
functionality to your existing Android
applications and you can find out more
about Android wear and the Developer
Preview by visiting our website here and
also I want you to go and join our
Google+ community and share what other
great ideas you have for Android wear as
well so I'm Wayne Piekarski I'll see you
next time